all you need is love except you know
when you don't want it so this is just a
video that kind of popped into my head
to do cuz on Twitter somebody kind of
asked me about shipping like I think
they might have asked specifically who I
shipped in something I can't remember
and I've never really talked too much
about shipping and I'm not really a
shipper just in case for some reason
you're not familiar with the terminology
shipping ship is short for relationship
and shipping is the practice of fans to
strongly desire that specific characters
within a TV show movie comic book
franchise whatever would become
romantically entangled and shippers are
the people who engage in this and it is
kind of an interesting bit of like
subculture within young it's not even
limited to geek circles in fandom in
general people who really sort of get
excited at the possibilities of who
could pair up and who would be best for
whom and yeah what I say I'm not a
shipper I want to be really clear I
don't disparage shippers however you
engage in your fandom of something if
that includes shipping awesome cool and
I also want because I'm not completely
above shipping it's not like I've never
done it before like the off the top of
my head the two that I would come up
with that yeah I shipped I ship - that
would be something like the the Justice
League cartoon I do ship Batman and
Wonder Woman and which is implied and
never made explicit which I love and
before they went there in Gotham
spoilers for season 3 yes it was season
3 that it happened
I II D and Oswald like hard there like
as soon as I saw those two in a scene
together I'm like oh god please and like
but but the thing is that those are kind
of the only examples I can come up with
off the top my head cuz fundamentally
that's not me and again not disparaging
it but the simple truth is I am somebody
who would remove forcibly with pliers
and a crowbar if necessary the romantic
subplots from probably 90% of all media
and it's not because I hate romance
I don't it's because I hate seeing a
romantic subplot shoved in where it
doesn't enhance anything where it
doesn't help where it drags things down
where it diverges from why I'm here and
since I'm not a shipper when those
connect when those characters start
hooking up you know that's not what I'm
here for so I get annoyed by it so I'm
trying to give some good go-to examples
cuz there are some things that have a
romantic subplot basically basically
baked into the DNA of it like I I don't
get hung up on it with James Bond films
although I mean part of that is with the
possible exception of aveva green's
character in Casino Royale they've never
really tried to be to pull a hole and
he's in love with this woman thing which
helps because that's that's part of the
thing is it's the heavily neon it like I
was resistant for a while on the firing
Leela thing I liked it much better as an
unrequited affection eventually that did
pan out and that did work oh here's a
real good example Highlander the
original Highland that what as far as
I'm concerned the only Highlander TV
show was okay but I never got into it
but in that original film there is an
awesome love story between the main
character Connor MacLeod and his wife
and
and I think everyone knows what
Highlander is but just in case you don't
I'll be super quick he is part of a race
of immortals he figures that out and
part of that is he can't have kids so
you know this woman that he loves he's
going to stay young she's gonna die
she's gonna get old and die but it's
very core to understanding who Connor is
as a person it's also to the tune of
Queens who wants to live forever written
for the movie there's a glorious
wonderful montage of her getting older
and him never stopping loving her and
ending with him holding this frail old
woman in his arms and looking down at
her and with the same look as if he was
seeing her in her 20s just as beautiful
as she ever was to him and it's awesome
and it's wonderful and amazing and then
later on in the same movie they decide
to have him hook up with a police
investigator who is who is on to him and
it's stupid and clunking comes out of
nowhere and gives us an awkward sex
scene and doesn't do anything to benefit
the story she ends up being a damsel in
distress but even that is unnecessary
there is a ton of stuff baked into the
narrative that is a reason for the final
showdown between Connor and the Kurgan
who's the villain you don't need to
force him into this situation by giving
him a new love interest he has a ton of
reasons to face this guy down already
we don't need that - so that's it
that little mini ramble I just went on
that's a good example of how I feel
about the vast majority of romantic
subplots in film television comic books
and in some ways I find it more
aggravating on in movies than I do in TV
and comics although it does bug me there
- I think being my issue with romantic
subplots and movies where the romance is
not central to the characters or the
premise
just kind of there is what drives me
crazy about that is when you'd make a
movie you've got a limited amount of
time you've got 90 minutes to two and a
half hours you know unless you're being
stupidly indulgent to lose time away
from whatever the thing is about in
order to do a romantic subplot I hate
that I like I said I would I would carve
this stuff out with a rusty butter knife
if I could it just drives me up the wall
it does still bother me on TV shows it
bothers me a little bit less because I'm
I do know that part of the reason TV
shows have a tendency to ship is that
the longer something runs eventually
you're just you're just looking for more
opportunities to feed the story unless
you're telling a story that has a really
clear final destination something like I
don't know Breaking Bad then eventually
you're going to hit a point in the
series of just you know we have to fill
a season of television again this year
and part of how you fill the time is
with more subplots what's an easy
subplot well let's have two characters
get together that'll get us another five
minutes per episode that's easily taken
care of we can get a focus in one
episode that and be half of that great
so now we now we filled some time so I
do understand that the necessity
especially in American television the
necessity to fill time because American
TV shows especially Network ones 20 plus
episodes the season yeah they need stuff
to do and that theoretically gives you
story possibilities so I get slightly
less annoyed by it in TV shows because
when it happens in TV shows it feels
more like an inevitability like uh-oh
we're at that point in the show's run
gotcha where whatever the the core
premise
of the thing was is he isn't carrying
the full weight of a season worth of
stories anymore and we need to have more
stuff in
I got it that's where we are and that's
where you tend to get you know various
ships and and hookups between characters
on TV shows you know where it wasn't
part of the initial core set up of the
story in the dynamic between the
characters you get those developed
relationships the ones that 10 that are
more likely to annoy me
usually three seasons in I'd say on
average as when you start really getting
those in a lot of shows and yeah that
again it it wouldn't bother me but I
feel like the romantic subplots are so
often totally detached and detachable
from the stories like you could remove
it and almost nothing else changes like
you'd change a little bit of dialogue
you maybe remove one scene that they
have together but then the overall story
and more primarily the plot that is the
main thrust of whatever it is whatever
show movie comic it is is unaltered and
that to me is something that is a
distraction and that's how I feel about
the vast majority of romantic subplots
now when romance is central to what
you're doing I can appreciate that I'm
not sure there's any TV shows that I've
really watched where that's the case but
well then you know what um I suppose
Brooklyn nine-nine III was initially
resisting of Amy and Jake
hooking up but eventually I warmth that
because that that started heading that
way in the first season so this was
obviously early plans this wasn't
something done out of desperation and
the way that relationship has developed
over the course of the show very
obviously had some thought put into it
because otherwise what you frequently
run into is the thing that I talked
about
when I talked about comic book tropes
that I hate which is that no one's
allowed to stay happy for very long and
that's the other thing that's really
aggravating about a lot of these ships
especially on TV which is that when a
couple of characters get together like
great they're gonna be happy for maybe
the remainder of this season and then
something's gonna go horribly wrong next
year because it has to because if
they're happy there's less tension
there's less conflict there's less drama
there's less story possibilities and so
that's the other thing that really
drives that is sort of specific to the
television and comic book version of
these things is you see two characters
get together and I mean anything well if
they're not planning to end this thing
anytime soon that's on borrowed time was
one of the things that really bugged me
about house which was a show I liked a
lot it became increasingly formed Wow um
I was gonna say increasingly formulaic
it was formulated from the beginning but
the formula was starting to wear thin
I think the season four was the best
season personally I don't know if I'm
alone in that but after that it started
to really get a bit repetitive and one
of the things they had a tendency to do
was to have various characters start
being together you know various doctors
on his team they did it with several of
them and then eventually season six I
think it was the very end of season five
they had house hook up with his boss
with cut I think season well would need
whatever it was so second to last season
was where the relationship played out
and and the finale from the season
before I forget how many seasons their
world where there's seven or were there
eight I don't know but when when he and
Cuddy started hooking up my immediate
thought was next year needs to be the
last season because this will not be
allowed to stand too much of houses
characterization is dependent on him
being miserable and if the next season
is the last season
then maybe he can have this and we'll
wrap everything up maybe they can
sustain this first season but they won't
be able to sustain it past that but the
next season wasn't the last season and
that entire thing blew up and then Cuddy
didn't even appear and the season that
followed she was written out of the show
and I don't know if that was because
Lisa Edelson didn't want to come back
maybe it was but I mean they also had
exhausted any possibilities for the
character they completely used her up
but she was a great character so that's
sort of my ramble and my issues with
romantic subplots and why I am NOT and I
don't think we'll ever really consider
myself to be a shipper even though every
now and then I'll be like maybe those
two so I don't want to ask for people's
thoughts on shipping in general because
I think then we'll just get it into a
debate of uh shipping stupid or shipping
rate or whatever but is there a romantic
subplot that particularly annoyed you
was there one that you wanted to see
happen that didn't whatever your
thoughts are along those lines or about
anything else that I've said please keep
it respectful drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's
also a whole bunch of buttons down there
including a link to the patreon check
them out if you feel like it they take
you places and I just remember folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]